Hunter Biden walks as president Trump
faces 100 years in jail 100 years behind
bars for president Trump as Hunter Biden
is given a sweetheart plea deal he's
allowed to walk for everything he's done
for the laptop for everything else that
we've seen over all the past years all
of the headlines all of the data all of
the little pieces of information that'll
come out the text messages the emails
everything we've seen all the pieces of
it the money laundering the influence
pedaling firing Ukrainian prosecutors
and it all comes down to Hunter Biden
given a plea deal
for money laundering and given a slap on
the wrist essentially gets probation
we'll dig into all of it
for this charge for his lying to the ATF
on a gun charge in Delaware while using
drugs imagine if that happened to any of
us